hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
is the 11th of December and you're
watching games Bucky's Microsoft may
have already spoken out about their
embarrassment over the very broken halo
the master chief collection but today
Sony have expressed much the same
sentiment over driveclub PlayStation UK
boss Fergal gara told IGN that Sony and
the developer are embarrassed by the
issues the game has faced since its
release in October Gaara said it's a
disappointment when you lay your soul
out as being for the players then what
you certainly don't want is games that
are not fully ready it certainly wasn't
any ill intention on behalf of the team
its ambitious as a game there is
embarrassed as we are and all you can do
in those situations is say sorry he
added that the promised free playstation
plus edition is still on hold until they
can rectify the current issues next up
American reviews publication Consumer
Reports has come out with a list of the
top five violent games of 2014 now would
be your time to guess which game topped
the list before I come right out and
tell you the publication labeled that
these games should quote never come
anywhere near your kids the list is as
follows taking out what number five was
sunset overdrive then came Assassin's
Creed unity followed by the admittedly
gory evil within the second atop spot
was grabbed by watch dogs and the most
violent game according to the
publication and surprising exactly no
one was grand theft auto 5 if violence
is so not your thing or you have
yourself a small human to buy a present
for this holiday season Consumer Reports
also published a list of the top five
games for kids these included Skylanders
trap team in the top spot followed by
Disney infinity Pokemon alpha sapphire
Omega Ruby super smash brothers and
little big planet 3 i'm personally not
altogether sure they didn't jot smash
brothers down on the wrong list there
but let me know what you think of the
games that earned a spot according to
sony the ps4 as best days are still
ahead of it sony exact fergal gara
explained i really believe it's here to
when you tend to see those titles come
through
thought to define the whole generation
the best is yet to come on the ps4 we've
seen a brilliant start with the mega
franchises like the FIFA's call of
duties and the Assassin's Creed's but
we've also seen some strong new IP
launched the likes of destiny and watch
dogs but i think that the ones that are
truly to define the generation are
probably still to come to be honest
among sony's big upcoming titles are
blood-borne uncharted for the order 1886
and no man's sky ask your question of
the day let me know which upcoming game
you're looking forward to most and why
you can add your games well for more
stories on things like a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar and weaver
and another final fantasy port coming to
the ps4 that is it for me today be sure
to check back same time tomorrow I'll
have my top 5 stories of the whole week
I will see you then